que rodrigo martinez par un
vice-président du collectif intérieur
gensse et infirmiers à l'hôtel dieu à
paris
bonsoir merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
sur rt france comment vivez-vous cette
recrudescence de l'épidémie actuelle
avec l'augmentation du nombre de cas
positifs
yat-il affluent dans votre hôpital alors
ce qu'on peut constater dans les
urgences
en règle générale c'est une augmentation
du nombre de passages de patients qu'aux
vide et ce à dire de plus en plus
compliqué à prendre en charge parce
qu'on est obligé de mettre en place des
filières kovy des noms coheed oui
sachant qu'il ya aussi des malades qui
ne sont pas forcément traité pour le
cabinet qui ont également le co lead
exactement en plus c'est à dire plus en
plus compliqué enfin la nuit on passe
notre temps elle doit un petit peu aux
chaises musicales c'est à dire on est
obligé de prendre des patients qui se
sont intégrés dans un circuit normal
qu'ils viennent pour un autre motif de
prise en charge
finalement on est en train de les tester
on voit qu'ils sont commis de plus on
est obligé de les réinjecter dans le
circuit de co vide
et pour le coup ça complique les prises
en charge toutes les nuits en fait et
puis en plus le manque de personnel fait
que ça devient de plus en plus
compliqués à pouvoir gérer ce genre de
situation c'est surtout ça qui arrive
donc aujourd'hui c'est ce manque de bras
justement pour suivre ces malades qui
sont notamment dans les services de
réanimation alors tout à fait alors on
sait que déjà en période hivernale les
taux d'occupation des réanimations
généralement avoisine les 80 90 % la
part des patients plus qui sont co vie
de plus sont plus en plus importantes on
dépasse les 70% pour l'ile-de-france et
pour saint denis c'est des chiffres
alarmants et en plus le manque de
personnel c'est vraiment savoir et on
est fatigué tout simplement à savoir que
du 1er octobre au 18 octobre
il y a eu mille 87 cas de soignants
testé positif pourtant on dit que les
soignants sont plutôt bien protégé
maintenant qu'il ya des masques à des
blue
des gants pourquoi ces soignants
pourquoi un tel taux en tout cas de
contaminer chez les soignants selon vous
on peut pas trop se l'expliquer mais une
chose est sûre c'est que dans l'ensemble
de la france
chaque fois j'ai des témoignages de
collègues qui me disent de manquer tout
simplement de matériel de protection ce
qu'on appelle les deux pays
c'est à dire les masques chirurgicaux
des masques ffp2 des gants voilà on est
un peu affluent vu sacrer un sacré
encore plus de tension pour les prises
en charge
parce que on a peur de revivre le manque
de matériel ce qu'on avait vécu durant
la première vague et en plus voilà on
est fatigué on nous a demandé gentiment
de vouloir annuler nos congés chose que
la plupart des collègues ont fait mais
on sait qu'on s'inscrive sur une course
à long terme et on voit avec un on a une
vision un peu obscur du de l'avenir
surtout les vacances de noël qui
s'approche on fait comme on peut on
essaye de tenir on essaye de limiter la
casse du côté des soignants qu'est-ce
qu'il faudrait selon vous que demandez
vous aujourd'hui pour justement vous
venir en aide
bah écoutez ça fait deux ans qu'on est
qu'on est en train de crier avec le
collectif inter agences qui a vraiment
des difficultés pour la prise en charge
des patients on parle de 24 millions de
passages aux urgences avec une
augmentation annuelle de 3% ça veut dire
que ces sept cent vingt mille patients
on devra de nouveau voir et on devra
absorber cette activité il est sûr qu'il
faut rendre l'hôpital attractif pour ça
on avait demandé d aucune augmentation
de faire une revalorisation des salaires
de 300 euros
on avait surtout en des plus de moyens
humains et plus de moyens matériels et
plus de lits en fait ne le problème est
toujours à la base et les problèmes de
lit on a du mal hospitalisés les
patients que ce soit dans un service
n'daou dans les services de réanimation
faut pas oublier qu'en 2019 il ya eu
trois mille quatre cents lits fermés et
on continue avec cette politique a pas
si longtemps on en a des collègues ont
témoigné de
deux fermetures de lits dans ce nombre
dans certaines régions et de réanimation
et ça devient encore de plus en plus
compliqué c'est certain
certains médecins certains de l'exécutif
également 10 on peut pas rouvrir délais
parce que de toute façon il faut du
personnel pour assurer justement c'est
ces ouvertures de lits que répondez vous
est ce que c'est possible ouvrir des
lits aujourd'hui alors tout à fait on
sait que pour pouvoir ouvrir des lits
justement c'est ce qui c'est ce qui
devient de plus en plus compliqué avec
le dialogue entre les soignants et les
ceux qui prennent les décisions
avec le silure il proposait par exemple
d'ouvrir 4010 c'est sur que derrière il
faut des soignants et à l'heure actuelle
on en a pas et on peut pas s'improviser
ni aide soignant ni un fermier ni
médecin il faut une formation
les infirmiers ces trois ans ces trois
ans d'études
il faut aussi d intégration qui sont a
suffi suffisamment longue on sait qu'il
faut six mois pour pouvoir être
complètement autonome d'un service
d'urgence ou dans un service de
réanimation qui était très technique et
très spécifiques
donc on n'est pas dupe on sait qu'on
pourra pas réouvrir délire et
improvisées comme ça d'un claquement de
doigts et ouvrir les 4000 lits de
réanimation ccc pas envisageable rodrigo
martinez comment et prier comment sont
pris en charge les malades depuis mars
il ya eu quand même beaucoup
d'évolutions les traitements aussi sont
moins lourds lorsque des malades
arrivent à l'hôpital
oui et non on va dire on sait maintenant
avec un petit peu de recul comment
prendre en charge les patients on sait
anticiper un peu plus
donc concrètement les séjours de
réanimation sont plus courts mais ça
n'empêche que on sait aussi que il ya
des patients qui sont entre les deux et
qu'on va devoir justement sur prendre en
charge aux urgences on va devoir les
hospitalisé et est par contre la moyenne
d'âge a diminué aussi donc il faut il
faudrait vraiment faire attention à ce
qu'on fait tous les jours au doigt on
doit veiller à ce que les patients ce
parce qu'ils sont vraiment sur le fil du
rasoir ils peuvent décompensé très
rapidement et on peut se retrouver en
difficulté très rapidement
merci beaucoup rodrigo martinez d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce soir sur arte
france